[Music]
tonight on Brian Ross investigates the
sex abuse scandal closes in on the
Vatican 1 Vatican Cardinals sentenced to
six years in prison for abusing
choirboys another from washington d.c
defrocked for decades of being a sexual
predator victims and investigators ask
what will it take for the church to wake
up they sought to do the same thing that
senior church leaders in the diocese we
investigated have done for decades burry
the sexual abuse by priests upon
children and cover it up forever
now the retired Pope Benedict blames it
all on homosexual cliques in the church
the same man who once slapped me on the
hand for asking why he wasn't doing more
to help victims and we'll hear from one
of the church's staunchest supporters
who says there is no crisis it's all a
myth we live in a time of
hyperventilation of where everything is
overheated plus our shoutout for the
student reporters at Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School in parkland Florida
these budding journalists remind us of
the media's unwavering commitment to
bearing witness even in the most
wrenching of circumstances from the law
and crime networks to D in New York City
this is Brian Ross investigates good
evening and welcome tonight Holy Week
the most solemn week of the Christian
religion a week that has already seen
the devastating fire at the notre-dame
Cathedral in Paris but it is a week that
ends in a celebration of resurrection
and already hundreds of millions of
dollars has been pledged to rebuild and
to restore the Cathedral to repair the
damage but for the Catholic Church there
is another kind of damage that is
proving much more difficult to repair
the ongoing damage caused by decades of
sexual abuse by priests against children
abuse that law enforcement officials
around the world allege has been ignored
or covered up by senior Vatican
officials now the FBI federal grand
juries and state attorneys general are
conducting the kinds of investigations
the church failed to do
this year alone two of the
highest-ranking Vatican officials
Cardinals were implicated in sexual
abuse cases Cardinal George Pell of
Australia convicted of the sexual abuse
of choir boys sentenced to six years in
prison the Vatican has yet to take any
action against Cardinal Pell who once
handled Vatican finances considered the
third highest ranking Church official in
the world and Cardinal Theodore
McCarrick the former Archbishop of
Washington DC defrocked expelled from
the church for sexually abusing minors
over decades across the United States
law enforcement officials are digging
back decades to document the sexual
abuse that went unchecked unpunished
they sought to do the same thing that
senior church leaders in the diocese we
investigated have done for decades burry
the sexual abuse by priests upon
children and cover it up forever
the Attorney General of Pennsylvania
Josh Shapiro issued the most damning
report so far implicating some 300
predatory priests involving more than
one thousand victims father Ed Graff
told a seventh-grader he abused that
what they were doing was okay because
the priest was an instrument of God
Monsignor Thomas been estado
nine-year-old give him all sex then
rinsed the boy's mouth out with holy
water to purify him these children
children surrounded by adults enabling
their abuse we're taught that this abuse
was not only normal but that it was holy
tonight one of those victims from
Pennsylvania joins us in our studio
Sean Daugherty Sean thank you for being
here we're also joined via Skype from
Chicago by Zach Heiner the executive
director of a victims rights support
group called snap and talking let me
start with you you were on the stage
there when the Attorney General made his
announcement what was the emotional act
for you as you watch that it was
incredible it was a moment that I
literally had been waiting my entire
adult life for for this my story and the
stories of all the other victims
that stage to finally be released to the
world and to have a state official stand
in the full capacity of their job to
defend us when that finally happened did
you feel people finally believed you
absolutely that that report is the
vindication that we all have waited for
that that something to hang our hat on
for people to believe Zach Haider in
Chicago this is happening around the
country state after state exposing
decades of abuse what's been the impact
on on victims and survivors really you
know we've in our organization we have
seen a lot of people come forward as a
result of the investigations but
Attorney General Shapiro's and the 17
that have started since that
investigation came forward I think this
is really as Sean said a vindication of
this the experiences that survivors have
gone through and a chance for the public
to really see these stories in their
full breadth and detail and recognize
the reality of these situations and the
fact that it is nationwide and are you
getting and hearing from more people who
are alleging they also were abused and
other recent cases we are hearing from
people every single time that things
happen such as a diocese releasing list
or a new investigation gets announced
and yes
there are current cases that are being
released we've heard of one today in
California 22 year old woman out there
there's cases ongoing in the Archdiocese
of Galveston Houston as well so this is
a current problem and one that needs
addressing Sean you recently confronted
the now defrocked priest who you say
abused you as a 10 year old boy
Reverend Joe George Cukor check and you
allowed CBS News correspondent Nikki
Vitesse to set up undercover cameras and
record the encounter let's watch this
CBS News set up hidden cameras what's up
George how you doing how's it
he's gonna ready to shake it obviously
so we'll try to make this as least
awkward as possible I guess so Shawn he
says he was sorry is that enough for me
him coming to just sit and meet with me
was enough I forgave him a long time ago
the importance of that confrontation for
me for my friend Brian that was with me
was more for the victim survivor family
to show survivors that you can gain
control back over your abuser you can
take your life back
and in along with that report that the
Attorney General now no one absolutely
no one in the world can say that I was
not abused by father George go check
Shawn we've got a question for you from
our control room from executive producer
Rhonda Swartz Rhonda there have been so
many cases but most of these priests
seem to have gone unpunished do you
think more should be in jail should
there be harsher consequences what we're
fighting every day in Pennsylvania to
totally eliminate the criminal statutes
of limitations commits on crimes sex
crimes committed against minor children
and we would like to fully eliminate the
statutes of limitations on civil
litigation as well as most victims it is
said from the CDC reports that most
victims of childhood sex abuse don't
come forward before the age of 52 but
for you you'd still like to see him
behind bars absolutely and and for me
from my case I will never be able to
charge him criminally as the United
States Supreme Court has ruled that
unconstitutional however if someone is
out there right now that could still be
in the statutes of limitation if someone
was sexually active was George Carter
check in the early 90s and early 2000s
we can still criminally charge George
Kasich you know we asked for comment
from the US Cardinal Sean O'Malley now
leading the church's own investigation
of this country but he declined to come
on our program citing the scheduling
conflict of Holy Week later we will hear
from the head of the Catholic League
which claims there is no crisis in the
church and reports of widespread abuse
are a myth but clearly there is a
problem at the very top of the Vatican
you Nancy Lally Pope Francis convened a
convocation of Cardinals to address the
issue earlier this year but summoned the
church said the Pope's effort to help
was a failure that he failed to
understand the scope or the nature of
the problem and that was underscored
earlier this month when the retired Pope
Benedict addressed the issue of sexual
abuse blaming it on the sexual
revolution of the 1960s and what he
called homosexual clicks inside the
church before he became Pope Benedict he
was Cardinal Ratzinger who was accused
then by victims of stalling
investigations of sexual abuse at the
Vatican leading to this now infamous
moment when I was a correspondent at ABC
News and confronted him that got slapped
on the hand by an exasperated Cardinal
that approached angry to even be asked
about the problem is emblematic
according to one of the men who has
spent decades trying to get justice from
the Vatican with little to show for John
Paul Lennon now living in Guatemala you
guys just don't get it you know it's
because in a sense they're always trying
to protect the church they have to let
down their guard otherwise they'll never
otherwise they'll never understand never
and otherwise there never would be real
changes in the in the Catholic Church so
Shawn and Zak what will it take for the
church to get it as a John Paul London
said Zak you know I think that society
is dragging the church towards getting
it a lot more you know in the zeitgeist
that we're in now and in the me to
movement era that we're in
I think people across our country
certainly more awakened to the realities
of sexual violence just how common this
crime occurs and that it is in fact is
perpetrated by people who are in
positions of authority and Trust and I
think that we are just so much further
ahead of this issue than church
hierarchy and church officials so I
think that the more that Catholics who
are currently in the pews speak out
against what's going on the more that
people are making noise and the more
that people begin to listen to and
believe survivors like Shawn and hear
their stories and learn from them that's
is going to make the church change its
secular outside pressure but Shawn do
you see the church still in a defensive
Crouch about this no absolutely they're
spending massive amounts of lobbying
dollars to keep the legislation down I
would echo what Zak said and through
that movement in the pews that is
finally going to put pressure on the
politicians because right now the church
hierarchy has more pressure on the
politicians than the citizens of
Pennsylvania and that is changing by the
minute in Pennsylvania but you think the
church is actually lobbying to prevent
the law from being expanded so victims
could come forward now and bring
criminal prosecution there's no thinking
about it it's fact the Pennsylvania
Catholic Conference of Bishops has a
lobbying arm of their conference and
they are using it and wielding it
heavily in Harrisburg at the Capitol and
that law change is pivotal you think to
making this really become it absolutely
especially the critical two year
look-back window for people like me
those depositions those civil cases the
information that we will learn from
those trials will save future
generations of children Sean Donnelly
and Zach Heiner thank you so much for
being here tonight we really appreciate
it when we come back the churches
staunch defender the president of the
Catholic League who says it's all a myth
we live in a time of hyperventilation of
where everything is overheated
you
we're back now with the president of the
Catholic League Bill Donohue mr. Donohue
thank you very much for joining us thank
you it's my pleasure on this holy week I
want to ask you some questions about a
problem the church has had to deal with
for decades now that is of sexual abuse
you have written there is no crisis and
much of this is a myth what in the world
do you mean by that well what I mean is
this but if you take a look at the John
Jay study on this the timeline where
most of these problems occurred was 65
to 85 it's not I said we don't have any
problems today but we're down in the
single digits that is to say you got
about 40,000 so if you throw in the the
deacons who are clergymen with the
priests you know around 50,000 clergymen
in the United States we're down to
single digits of one of an credible
accusation made in the last 10 years
you know tonight there's been a problem
there's been a huge problem thousands of
thousands of the 60s 70s and 80s right
we don't have the crisis in the United
States today that's wrong over well
isn't it a crisis though that it hasn't
really been addressed that there's been
an attempt to cover this up essentially
well certainly Brian you're right if the
timeline is earlier and what what the
church did in the 70s was a disgrace
particularly in the seminaries in
defensible and in the 1980s not much
better they began to turn the corner a
little bit later see the the bill came
to in 2002 when the Boston Globe came
out with its report that was about the
damage that occurred earlier so what I'm
saying is this when you had the the
Dallas reforms there in 2002 when they
made a lot of changes in the Catholic
Church if you take a look at the
incidences per year they're minuscule
I don't know of a single institution in
society today which has a better
situation with the with the sexual abuse
of minors today than the Catholic Church
you think the church has handled this
appropriately I think they've done a
very good job in the United States
that's why we're down into the single
digits single conscience meaning what
meaning like the average number of
credible accusations made against the
priests out of 50 thousand in with the
Deacons is around the area of three four
five six seven eight a year we're still
coming to terms with the thousands
of sexual abuse cases well this is
decades past
for example the Pennsylvania grand jury
report from last year more than 300
members of the church right do you know
that almost every one of them are either
dead or out of ministry they just had
395 priests mentioned in Illinois for
the whole state but you freed in 94 them
are dead or out of ministry well it's
not the time to ignore it though is it
you have to come to terms of this are
you good no I think that I think we're I
think what you might be getting at is
that a lot of Catholics are angry
certainly myself when you find out we
still don't have the answers do we
deceive our McCarrick why was he
promoted out of New Jersey to become an
archbishop and in a cardinal in
Washington DC he was a predator and we
still don't have the answers some people
knew and they didn't touch so did that
extent there is a big problem that isn't
find out but that is a scandal isn't it
absolutely it makes me makes it makes me
angry I'm defending the church but let
me take that
I don't defend the church's wrongdoers
I'm here to defend the church against
wrongdoing and I'm not going to be the
church's waterboy I was I was correctly
quoted New York Times a number of years
ago I'm not going to defend the
indefensible I am simply saying yes of
course there's been a problem in the
Catholic Church and it's ongoing in
other parts of the world today in the
United States to say that we haven't
made great strides I think is simply
that is a myth well we asked Cardinal
O'Malley to appear here today I can't
because of Holy Week but he said his
spokesman said we don't think it's a
myth we think there's a crisis well
that's in time he's entitled to if he
has problems they're in the seminaries
which he does I hope he cleans it up but
he disagrees with let's you say well he
can he can say what he wants I look you
know what it is a lot of Catholics lack
the guts to come out and say what I'm
saying we've made tremendous progress
they don't want to offend people by
saying oh my god are you trying to say
shoving it under the rug all I'm simply
saying is I'm a social scientist I'm a
doctorate in sociology I look at the
data when we find out that the number of
credible accusations against priests
over the last 12 13 14 years is very is
minuscule if people want to say we still
have a problem well they can go ahead
and make their argument and then tell me
that my doubt or wrong which is not my
data
that's the Bishop's daughter he's one of
the bishops by the way Pope Benedict has
written recently and you supported him
he blamed it on the sexual revolution of
the 60s and talks about homosexual
cliques
look you've got two things here I would
say as a sociologist you have to look at
the external and the internal you can't
look at the situation in a social vacuum
obviously if it took place between 65
and 85 what was going on then in the
West the sexual revolution
yes corruption within the church but
that followed the same thinking they
were teaching in the seminaries that
every sexual act was okay including
deviant sexual acts in many of the
seminaries in the 90s they were never
teaching that pedophilia was okay there
oh yes they were and I can check and
prove it to you they were teaching that
I'm turning to a view what I am telling
you that there's not a single sexual
deviant act and I'll give you the name
of the book it's called human sexuality
by Anthony cosmic Kos ni ki people
should read he's a former priest the
book human sexuality by crooks and Bauer
read what they say there's not a sick
sexual a sexual act that they couldn't
defend and it was taught in the
seminaries in the 1970s that's one of
the reasons now look if you're a normal
guy and you get some crackpot priest
telling seminarians that every form of
sexual expression is equal the average
guy is not going to go out and act on it
but what if you have a problem it was
still a crime to have a sexually abused
a child oh listen if you had to build on
your rule I would have thrown them out a
long time ago I have done something a
lot of these priests and bishops have
never done
I reported police to the authority when
I was 25 and I didn't need anybody from
the Catholic Church to tell me that it
was wrong I I think these bishops who
didn't report it and what happened in
Boston by the way why was Boston the
epicenter where O'Malley's at I'll tell
you why it fits in with the argument of
Benedict and build out of you that's
where the sexual revolution really took
place they let everybody do whatever
they want Gagan Shanley Porter you can
go right down Paul Shanley in particular
and they were protected by Cardinal
Lauri was protected by Cardinal Banderas
oh yeah it didn't happen in Mississippi
it happened in Boston Bill Donohue
president of the Catholic League thank
you very much for joining us thank you
thanks
coming up our shout out some remarkable
journalists still in high school what
they did to persevere
you
our shout out tonight to all the
reporters who this week were awarded
Pulitzer Prizes and for the Pulitzer
committee itself which this year chose
to honor a select group of reporters who
did not win right before I announce who
they are I want to break with tradition
and offer my sincere admiration for an
entry that did not win but that should
give us all hope for the future of
journalism in this great democracy the
entry is from the staff of the
eagle-eyes student newspaper at Marjory
Stoneman Douglas High School in parkland
Florida which submitted the obituaries
of 17 coaches and classmates who were
killed during a tragic shooting in their
school in February 2018 the eagle-eyes
submission stated that the student
reporters and editors had to quote put
aside our grief and recognize our role
as both survivors journalists and loved
ones of the deceased end quote
these budding journalists remind us of
the media's unwavering commitment to
bearing witness even in the most
wrenching of circumstances in service to
a nation whose very existence depends on
a free and dedicated press there is hope
in their example even as security
threats to journalists are greater than
ever and there is hope even if some
wrongly degrade the media as the enemy
of the very democracy it serves of
course the press will endure because as
the founding fathers knew well there can
be no democracy without it that is
something Rebecca Smith Wendy Winters
robbed hyacinth Gerald Fishman and John
McNamara understood too they understood
it when they went to work last June at
the Capitol Gazette in Annapolis
Maryland and were gunned down by a
madman who opened fire in their newsroom
it is what Jamal could show he
understood as well when he bravely wrote
truth to power at the Washington Post
before being murdered in October 2018
inside the Saudi consulate in Turkey in
all 63 professional journalists
worldwide were killed this year
according to reporters without borders
that is a 15
cent increase in journalists who lost
their lives for simply trying to do
their jobs and their spirit this year's
winning work reflects yet again a steely
resolve in upholding the highest
principles and ideals of this noble
profession a sobering and important
reminder that's our program for this
week we'll see you back here again next
week good night
you